no
[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional
24 hoy dedicamos este espacio a la
economía y a uno de los metales más
preciados el oro considerado como el
activo refugio por excelencia en épocas
de crisis globales cómo funciona el
mercado del oro quien lo controla un
particular puede comprar lingotes donde
se guardan para salir de dudas hemos
invitado a ignacio sáenz iglesias
muchísimas gracias ignacio por estar con
los ocho gracias a vosotros por estar
ignacio usted es español afincado en
francia
especialista de la cotización del oro y
responsable de operaciones de la startup
creada en burdeos verá cash que lleva en
funcionamiento desde el año 2015 cuenta
con 30 mil clientes y durante el año
pasado en plena pandemia hubo una
especie de boom de nuevas inscripciones
y mucha gente tenía miedo de que se
repitiera la crisis desatada por las
supremes en 2008 y empezó a comprar oro
puede ser efectivamente nosotros
triplicamos incluso cuadruplicamos en
de marzo a abril el número de clientes
nuevos que se escribió seguramente
buscando una solución una alternativa un
poco de ahorro y se pensaron en el oro
como solución algo más seguro que no
fuera el dinero en los bancos porque al
final estaríamos en una composición
similar a la de lehman brothers de 2008
cómo funciona cualquier particular puede
venir y llamarlo llamarles y con claro
si cualquier particular puede comprar
oro y más en ver a casa
es bastante sencillo el particular o
incluso menor una empresa pueden comprar
o se inscriben en la plataforma rellena
una serie de informaciones que
necesitamos para comprobar su identidad
y bueno saber un poco dónde vive y tal
si son
necesidades en tema de lucha contra el
blanqueamiento de capitales una vez que
hemos validado su ficha puede empezar a
invertir el cliente envía dinero y
nosotros cuando recibimos ese dinero
compramos oro y lo metemos en su cuenta
y el cliente entonces dispone de un
número de gramos que puede utilizar con
su tarjeta más cerca que le ponemos a
disposición o con la aplicación móvil se
puede comprar con oro a través de la
tarjeta exactamente lo que comprarse un
al final un cliente no esto tenga la
tarjeta del banco y la tarjeta verá que
así la tarjeta beracasa está adosada a
una cuenta en gramos de oro y qué
ventajas tiene bueno el oro tiene
ventajas históricas y bueno algunas de
las ventajas son que el valor intrínseco
que tiene siempre va a ser reconocido
siempre vale algo el peso de algo hoy en
día una moneda de un euro
si tuviéramos que valorizar la al peso
del metal que lleva dentro no valdría
gran cosa entonces el valor intrínseco
es una de las ventajas principales luego
es reconocido en todo el mundo a un
valor refugio como tú decías entonces
normalmente cuando en épocas de un
crecimiento económico complicado el oro
tiende a subir y donde se aguarda esto
siempre me lo he preguntado se guarda en
bancos o ahí no sé con una especie de
almacén de alta seguridad bueno nosotros
en ver acá si lo tenemos guardado en el
puerto franco de ginebra en suiza no
pues no porque sea suiza sino porque uno
de los lugares más seguros del mundo y
sobre todo desaconsejamos a los
particulares tenerlo en casa por pues se
puede robar las pólizas de seguro no lo
cubren entonces es complicado hay gente
que lo guarda debajo del colchón si
nosotros tenemos algún episodio
complicado con agua con algún cliente
que se lo quiso mandar a casa lo enterró
en el jardín y bueno
no se aconseja hacer es
bueno
pregunta quien tiene las mayores
reservas de oro en el mundo supongo que
son los estados efectivamente son son
los estados bueno el líder indiscutible
es eeuu y luego en el top 10 tenemos las
potencias que nos podemos imaginar a
francia alemania china bueno y entre
ellos están también en dos organismos
como son el fondo montario internacional
y el banco central europeo y luego ya
hay otra serie de entidades privadas que
gestionan fondos que gestionan este efe
el oro el oro papel y en
hay particulares que tienen muchísimo
seguramente no se conocen con certeza
pues entre otras cosas porque al final
cada uno es un poco se guarda desde sus
inversiones en tampoco va a decir
públicamente que tiene un montón de oro
en su casa o en algún sitio pero hay que
tener en cuenta que el orden que estamos
hablando hasta ahora es oro de inversión
que es un oro con especificidades muy
precisas y es simplemente el otra
inversión es simplemente el 20 por
ciento de todo el oro que se ha extraído
de la tierra unas 200 mil toneladas por
redondear hay que darse cuenta que
países como india o algunas familias de
las familias reales del golfo pérsico
tienen mucho oro en forma de joyas el 50
por ciento del oro es traído la tierra
está en forma de joyas y se sigue
extrayendo ahora se sigue extrayendo oro
en los países más productores son eeuu
rusia china y quizás de cerquita de ésta
australia y canadá y se extraen unas
tres mil quinientas toneladas al año
desde hace diez años bueno vamos a ver
un poco la evolución del mercado de el
oro una onza de oro equivale a unos 30
gramos
y se llegó a cotizar a mediados
del 2020 a 2000 dólares en plena
pandemia casi un máximo histórico y
luego bajo bajo en
septiembre que pasó en estas últimas
semanas para que bajara el precio del
oro efectivamente la onza la onza troy
es la medida de utilizar el oro son 31,1
gramos el oro suele marcar picos
históricos en momentos puntuales como
pasos más avanzadas la crisis de la sub
prime ha pasado ahora en 2020 2021 con
el tema de la pandemia ahora septiembre
ha habido un evento relacionado con el
gigante chino de la inmobiliaria
evergrande y esto seguramente es lo que
ha hecho que el mercado está inestable
porque puede la gente se está imaginando
que puede tener un cierto riesgo
sistémico y un riesgo que podría
causar problemas en todo el sistema
financiero y un poco lo que puede hacer
que el oro esté bajando en este momento
y quien fija el precio del oro están los
bancos de lingotes que no
al cien por cien en ese precio está ahí
hoy en día hay dos precios que se
utilizan en el euro en el mercado del
oro el primero es el fixing que es un
precio que se fija dos veces en londres
es un poco el organismo de referencia
del oro el bm y luego hay otro precio
que es el spot el fixing es muy
utilizado en el mercado para los grandes
actores y el spot es más utilizado en el
día a día el espacio es un precio que se
va recuperando de las bolsas de los
diferentes países que van abriendo y
cerrando entonces tiene un curso que va
prácticamente desde el domingo por la
noche hasta el hasta el viernes por la
noche y al final el precio lo marca el
volumen que se intercambian esos
mercados de oro físico y atención de
europa papel también actualmente se
cotiza hemos visto a unos mil 754
dólares
pero parece que hay una especie de
repunte podríamos hablar de que vuelve
la fiebre del oro
el tema de la fiebre del oro al final el
oro siempre vuelve cuando hay un
problema una tensión geopolítica cuando
hay un problema de incertidumbre un
problema como la pandemia como anunciar
el gordo como el lehman brothers o ever
gum entonces no podemos hablar para mí
de una fiebre en particular al final son
episodios febriles que yo les llamo que
van en función un poco de la situación y
del contexto internacional a pesar de
eso es seguro invertir en nor a pesar de
que haya bajadas y bueno es bastante
fiable digamos porque no tiene la
volatilidad que pueden tener por ejemplo
las cripto monedas como como el pico
entonces al final es un veloz refugio
conocido bueno hay una fecha que va a
ser muy importante es el 1 de enero de
2023 es una fecha clave para el mercado
del oro porque entra en vigor en reino
unido el acuerdo de basilea 3 que va a
impactar directamente en el
funcionamiento de los bancos de lingotes
porque además es en londres donde
concentran la mayoría que va a pasar
exactamente en esa fecha bueno el
acuerdo el tercer acuerdo de basilea no
viene a suplir los anteriores acuerdos
de basilea sino a complementarlo
se suponía que iba a ser en enero de
2022 ahora se ha vuelto a retrasar la
fecha por una cuestión de justamente de
la pandemia
son una serie de reformas financieras
que cuyo objetivo es justamente evitar
que haya problemas como el que hubo en
2008-2009 con lehman brothers entonces
van a obligar a los bancos a mantener
una reserva de oro físico mayor que a la
que están obligados hoy entonces los
bancos actualmente están se están
cubriendo sus posiciones con una parte
de oro físico una parte muy importante
de oro papel si esta obligación es de
mantener una reserva de oro físico más
alta valor una demanda de oro físicos
más alta y entonces se supone que esto
va a llevar a un aumento del precio del
oro pero bueno esto es la teoría el año
la fecha es de 2023 y luego entrará en
vigor un poquito más tarde algunos años
más tarde bueno antes hablábamos de la
descripto monedas
parece que el dinero clásico está
pasando un poco de moda
se vuelve bueno al oro y sobre todo se
apuesta por estas cripto monedas pero el
oro y el bitcoin por ejemplo tiene una
correlación un poco negativa porque con
el aumento de los precios del bitcoin
una gran cantidad de dinero se mueve del
oro al bitcoin y en qué medida esto
impacta en la cotización del oro bueno
lo primero es que al final
pensamos hace unos años que el que el
efectivo se iba a terminar o que la
forma de consumir que teníamos hace unos
años podría llegar a una sociedad sin
cash como como se denomina y al final yo
creo que es bastante cultural aquí en
francia tenemos utilizamos la tarjeta
para todo para comprar el pago un café
que valen un euro de salud en españa o
en alemania por ejemplo si se sigue
utilizando muchísimo el caso entonces la
sociedad sin casa que pensamos que iba a
llegar bastante rápido no va a pasar la
sociedad sin vinilos
y entonces bueno si tenemos nuevas
formas de pago nuevas formas de consumir
está el pago sin contacto
veremos a ver cómo se comporta eso
también con las cristo monedas como
decimos y luego las cristo morales al
final no se resume hoy en día todo el
bitcoin el bitcoin es la más conocida la
precursora de la que más se habla la más
mediatizada y seguramente no sea el
bitcoin la que utilizamos desde hace
unos años para en nuestro en nuestro día
a día en nuestro cotidiano
yo creo que el bitcoin por ejemplo hoy
está sobre todo utilizado para especular
y el oro para protegerse
entonces al final como tú decías hay
muchos inversores que pasan de limpio in
al oro a mí no me extraña porque se
están diciendo yo voy a entrar ganar con
especulando con el bitcoin y si tengo
alguna pérdida de posición en bitcoin
disminuye entonces aseguró un poco
protejo un poco en mi otra parte del
patrimonio comprando oro entonces
efectivamente los inversores han
entendido que el bitcoin y el oro son
totalmente complementarios craft y le
quería preguntar bueno los bancos
clásicos a veces se ven amenazados por
las cripto monedas o también tal vez por
esta por la empresa verá cash de gente
que puede comprar oro y utilizar tarjeta
y pagar en oro como se han tomado los
bancos de burdeos bueno como nosotros no
estamos no tengo una agencia en burdeos
pueden ser los bancos que hablemos de
los bancos seguros y de francia es casi
igual son muy reticentes a mandar dinero
a empresas a mandar dinero que los
clientes les piden su dinero de los
clientes a empresas como nosotros o
incluso han llegado a bloquear las
tarjetas de los clientes que quieren
comprar oro en ver acaso que quieren
comprar christo monedas
seguramente sea porque bueno al final
son la competencia y luego creo que hoy
en día se ve un poco a la cristo moneda
o incluso al oro que es algo muy muy
antiguo se le ve como algo un poco
oscuro con menos medidas de lucha contra
el banca miento de capital y el fraude y
las realidades que nosotros hacemos
tomamos las mismas medidas que los
bancos bueno pues muchísimas gracias
ignacio sáenz iglesias responsable de
operaciones de veras casi especialista
en la cotización del oro por todas estas
aclaraciones y mucha suerte ha sido un
placer muchas gracias a vosotros y
muchas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir en internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto amigos
[Aplausos]
[Música]